Welcome to the first episode of the Kickstarter funded season four of 99% invisible now weekly from here on out And I'm excited to announce the launch of radio topia from PRX a collective of the best story driven audio shows on the planet We'll have more information about radio topia at the end of the show So thank you all for your generosity and support. We're gonna make you proud Here we go. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The greatness of New York is perhaps most spectacularly seen in its buildings. While other cities have spread outward, New York has been forced to build upward. Like the best of these stories, the two bitter rivals started out as best friends.
欢迎收听由Kickstarter资助的《99%隐形》第四季的第一集，从现在开始我们将改为每周更新，我很高兴地宣布来自PRX的Radiootopia正式上线，这是一个汇集了全球最好的故事驱动型音频节目的集体。我们在节目结束时会有关于Radiootopia的更多信息，所以感谢大家的慷慨和支持。我们会让你们为我们感到骄傲，我们开始了。这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马斯。纽约的伟大，或许在其建筑中得到了最壮观的体现。当其他城市向外扩展时，纽约却被迫向上建造。就像这些最好的故事一样，这两个水火不容的死敌最初是最好的朋友。
William Van Allen? Van Allen was kind of the archetype of architect as artists. He looked at buildings as art and he wanted to revolutionize in that way. And Craig Severance. Craig Severance was very much architect as businessman. He looked at buildings as a way to make the land pay. They were business partners. And as partners, they were incredible together because you had Van Allen as the architect as artists and you have
威廉·范·艾伦？范·艾伦可以说是“作为艺术家的建筑师”的原型。他将建筑视为艺术，并希望以此进行彻底的变革。还有克雷格·塞弗伦斯。克雷格·塞弗伦斯则非常符合“作为商人的建筑师”的形象。他将建筑视为让土地产生效益的一种方式。他们曾是商业伙伴。作为合伙人，他们在一起堪称绝配，因为你拥有作为艺术家的建筑师范·艾伦，还有
Severance as the businessman making everything run on time making things work efficiently and together They were able to do quite a bit, but they were not just business partners. They stood up at each other's weddings Van Allen was the godfather to Severance's daughter, but years of working together had taken its toll Sadly, we don't know exactly what the sort of precipitating factor was. Other than the fact that there were some records that I discovered just about and I wanted to change plans sort of continuously running over budget. And to someone like Severance, that wasn't going to stand. And so they were late on plans, they weren't delivering.
作为商人的塞弗伦斯，让一切按时运行，让事情高效运转。他们齐心协力完成了相当多的成就，但他们不仅仅是商业伙伴。他们出席彼此的婚礼，范·艾伦是塞弗伦斯女儿的教父，但多年的共事最终还是付出了代价。遗憾的是，我们并不知道具体导火索是什么，除了我发现的一些关于预算不断超支以及想要更改计划的记录。对于塞弗伦斯这样的人来说，这是绝不能容忍的。因此他们的计划迟迟未能交付，也没有按时交工。
And I think that Severance at a certain point said, you know, I could do this better on my own. Telling our story today is Neil Bascom. My name is Neil Bascom. He wrote a great book about this called Higher, a historic race to the sky and the making of a city. On the author of Higher and a number of other books. At the time of the Van Allen and Severance break up, New York City was undergoing a boom
而且我认为塞弗伦斯在某个时刻说，你知道的，我自己也能把这事做好。今天给我们讲述这个故事的是尼尔·巴斯肯。我叫尼尔·巴斯肯。他写了一本关于这段历史的好书，名为《更高：直冲云霄的历史竞赛与一座城市的打造》。我是《更高》以及其他几本书的作者。在范·艾伦和塞弗伦斯分道扬镳的时候，纽约市正在经历一场
like nothing ever seen before. Massive wealth concentrated on this tiny island turned Manhattan into the most valuable property in human history, and when property gets valuable, we build up. The roaring 20s, the stock market is going crazy. Real-stay prices are going through the roof. A skyscraper is a machine designed to turn the land into money. At least, that's how severance viewed skyscrapers.
空前绝后的经济繁荣。巨大的财富集中在这个小岛上，把曼哈顿变成人类历史上最有价值的房产，而当房产变得有价值时，我们就开始往高处建造。在咆哮的二十年代，股市疯狂飙升，房地产价格飞涨。摩天大楼就是一台旨在将土地变成金钱的机器。至少，塞弗伦斯就是这样看待摩天大楼的。
There were talks of skyscrapers of 1,200 feet, 1,500 feet. I mean, off the charts. It was a symbol both of the economics and also of the times. I mean, the culture was we won everything faster, higher, better, and so it sort of all came together into the skyscraper race. At this point in 1928, late 1928, Van Allen's career is basically, you know, in the basement. I mean, he's not getting many commissions.
当时有传言说要建造1200英尺、1500英尺高的摩天大楼，简直是突破天际。这既是经济的象征，也是时代的象征。当时的代码文化是我们一切都要更快、更高、更好，所以这一切最终都汇聚成了这场摩天大楼竞赛。此时在1928年底，范·艾伦的职业生涯基本上可以说是跌入谷底。我的意思是，他接不到什么项目。
Meanwhile, Severance is going crazy. I mean, he's getting commission many commissions. Meanwhile, Severance is going crazy. I mean, he's getting commission after commission on big building, after big building. So in late 1928, Walter Chrysler, founder of the Chrysler Car Company, came to New York City and bought a plot of land and wanted to build what he referred to as a monument to me. Van Allen had already been working on plans
与此同时，塞弗伦斯却疯狂地接项目。我的意思是，他一个接一个地接到大楼的项目。因此，在1928年底，克莱斯勒汽车公司的创始人沃尔特·克莱斯勒来到纽约市买下一块土地，并想要建造他口中“属于我的纪念碑”。范·艾伦当时已经在为这块地的
for the previous owner of that plot, and Chrysler decided to hire him to develop that plan into what would become the Chrysler building. Chrysler, I think, was in his own way a revolutionary. It was very committed to art and design, and I think saw in a very real way a kindred spirit in Van Allen. Meanwhile, downtown at Forty Wall Street, Van Allen's ex-partner Craig Severance was building the Manhattan Company Building. And Severance's building was very different,
前主人制定计划，而克莱斯勒决定雇佣他，将该计划发展成为后来的克莱斯勒大厦。我认为克莱斯勒以他自己的方式是一个革新者。他非常致力于艺术和设计，并且我认为他在范·艾伦身上真正看到了一个志同道合的灵魂。与此同时，在市中心的华尔街40号，范·艾伦的前合伙人克雷格·塞弗伦斯正在建造曼哈顿公司大厦。塞弗伦斯的建筑非常不同，
key to exactly to his personality. The Manhattan Company Building was downtown, the Chrysler Building was uptown, Severance was an investor in this building, it was being funded primarily by a man named George Orstrom who was considered the boy wonder of Wall Street. He was 34, he was incredibly rich, incredibly quickly, and their building was in a very real way was to make money. Wow, the Chrysler building was to sort of make
这与其个性息息相关。曼哈顿公司大厦在市中心，克莱斯勒大厦在市uptown，塞弗伦斯是这座大厦的投资者，它主要由一个名叫乔治·奥斯特姆的人资助，他被认为是华尔街的神童。他34岁就极其富有，财富积累得极快，而他们的建筑在很大程度上就是为了赚钱。哇，克莱斯勒大厦是为了纪念克莱斯勒所取得的成就，也是为了在建筑领域开辟新天地。当时，卡斯·吉尔伯特的伍尔沃夫大厦傲视群雄，
a monument to what Chrysler had achieved, but also to sort of break new ground in architecture. At the time, Cass Gilbert's Woolworth building towered over everything. 792 feet tall. It's the tallest building in New York. And in true monument to me fashion, Chrysler set his sights on his building being taller than the Woolworth building, the tallest in the city. And even though the Manhattan Company Building didn't quite have the same motivation to be the tallest to celebrate one man's greatness, the team decided that they wanted to take
高达792英尺。它是纽约最高的建筑。为了彰显“纪念我”的作风，克莱斯勒将目标定为让自己的大厦比全城最高、身为城市之巅的伍尔沃夫大厦还要高。尽管曼哈顿公司大厦没有那种为了庆祝某个男人的伟大而成为最高建筑的同等动机，但团队还是决定夺走
the crown from Woolworth and be the tallest. I think the motivation initially for the Wall Street building, for the Manhattan Company building is one, because of the cost of land, downtown in Wall Street, you have to build high. They got their spreadsheets out and decided exactly how high that would be. And then they decided to go a little bit higher to have the impromotor of the World's tallest building, which when you're selling office space is something that is a real estate agent, you can sort of hand out a card and says, do you want to work in the world's tallest building, which when you're selling office space is something that is a real state agent, you can sort of hand out a card and says, do you want to work in the world's tallest
伍尔沃夫大厦的王冠，成为世界第一高楼。我认为华尔街大厦、曼哈顿公司大厦最初的动机之一，是因为土地成本的原因，在市中心华尔街，你必须往高处建造。他们拿出电子表格，精确计算了建筑的高度。然后他们决定建得更高一点，以便拥有“世界最高建筑”的光环。当你销售办公空间时，作为一名房地产经纪人，你可以递出一张卡片说：“你想在世界最高建筑里办公吗？当你在销售办公空间时，作为一名房地产经纪人，你可以递出一张卡片说，你想在世界最高
building? So it was a sales tactic as well as an economic decision. And so the race was on. Two ex partners, Van Allen with the Chrysler Building and Severance with the Manhattan Company Building were going to battle it out for supremacy on the skyline. Initially the Chrysler Building and Severance with the Manhattan Company Building. We're going to battle it out for supremacy on the skyline. Initially, the Chrysler Building was the first to announce its height. Chrysler and Van Allen were a little bit further along. And so they announced in early 1929 that they're going to roughly 820 feet,
建筑里办公吗？”所以这既是一种销售策略，也是一项经济决策。于是，竞赛开始了。两位前合伙人——拥有克莱斯勒大厦的范·艾伦和拥有曼哈顿公司大厦的塞弗伦斯，将在天际线的统治地位上展开一番较量。最初，克莱斯勒大厦是第一个宣布其高度的。克莱斯勒和范·艾伦的进度要稍微靠前一些。因此他们在1929年初宣布，他们将建造大约820英尺高，
which is taller than the Woolworth at 792. Well, a couple months after that, Craig Severance comes out and says, well, we're building to $840 feet. And then you have this over the course of that year, particularly that summer, even as the buildings are going up, even as the setting the foundation, even as they're ordering steel, van Allen and Severance are both changing their plans, both not knowing what the other person is doing, but sure that their respective losses want to go higher. And I think at this point they very much want to beat each other.
这比792英尺高的伍尔沃夫大厦还要高。嗯，在那之后的几个月里，克雷格·塞弗伦斯站出来说，嗯，我们要建840英尺高。然后在这之后的一年里，特别是那个夏天，甚至在建筑物拔地而起的时候，甚至在打地基的时候，甚至在订购钢铁的时候，范·艾伦和塞弗伦斯都在不断修改他们的计划，双方都不知道对方在做什么，但都确信各自的损失想要去得更高。我想在这一点上，他们非常想击败对方。
But it wasn't just a height race. It was also a speed race. At the point in the summer of 1929, when both of these buildings are going up very fast, it's very much who can beat the wall worth building first, who can release that first statement saying, world's tallest building. And the public was into it. It was a race almost weekly. There were newspaper articles about this building's going higher.
但这不仅仅是一场高度竞赛，这也是一场速度竞赛。在1929年夏天的那个时候，这两座建筑都在以极快的速度拔地而起，这在很大程度上取决于谁能率先击败伍尔沃夫大厦，谁能率先发表声明说：“这是世界最高建筑”。公众对此十分着迷。这几乎成了一场每周都在进行的竞赛。报纸上不断出现关于这座建筑将建得更高的文章。
Christel was going to be 900 feet. My husband company building is going to be 950 feet. Severance wins, Van Allen wins. I mean, all these sort of premature statements, and it was very much covered in the press and all of the New York newspapers of that time, which were many. Big, you know, front page photographs,
克莱斯勒大厦将达到900英尺。曼哈顿公司大厦将达到950英尺。塞弗伦斯赢了，范·艾伦赢了。我的意思是，所有这些诸如此类的过早断言，都受到了当时许多纽约报纸的大肆报道。你知道的，有醒目的头版照片，
it was pretty incredible. But both Chrysler and Van Allen were not content just being the fastest on the tallest. Van Allen remembers a time going into Chrysler's office when Chrysler's on the floor, you know, with plans spread out on the carpet, you know, looking at how the lobby is going to be set up. Walter Chrysler was very interested in art and architecture. And so he wanted a beautiful building, one of a building like none other in the world. Meanwhile, at the Manhattan Company Building. Basically, what's happening on the Manhattan
这真是太不可思议了。但克莱斯勒和范·艾伦并不满足于仅仅成为最快或最高。范·艾伦还记得有一次走进克莱斯勒的办公室，当时克莱斯勒正趴在地板上，你知道的，地毯上铺满了图纸，在研究大堂该如何布局。沃尔特·克莱斯勒对艺术和建筑非常感兴趣。因此他想要一座美丽的建筑，一座世界上独一无二的建筑。与此同时，在曼哈顿公司大厦，
Company Building is they're just adding floors. They're saying, well, the foundation will be able to do this if we had four floors, if we had 10 floors, we had this little flag at the top, we can go higher. So it was almost incremental movements on the Manhattan Company Building. On the Chrysler Building, they were achieving
基本上，曼哈顿公司大厦所做的事情就是不断增加楼层。他们说，如果我们增加四层、增加十层、在顶部加一个小旗杆，我们的地基就能承受得住，我们就能建得更高。所以这在曼哈顿公司大厦上几乎是渐进式的变动。而在克莱斯勒大厦上，他们则是通过
last-minute height advantages in two ways. One, originally the dome of the Chrysler building that arched dome was much more compact. As you see it now, it's almost like it's stretched out. And that happened because of the height race. They wanted to find more floors, they wanted to get some more height. And so that elegant elongated dome that we love on the Chrysler building was the result of the silly high-rise. But the sneaky masterstroke that ultimately led the Chrysler building was the result of the silly high-race. But the sneaky masterstroke
两种方式获得了最后的height优势。第一，最初克莱斯勒大厦的拱形穹顶要紧凑得多。正如你现在所看到的，它看起来像是被拉长了。这是因为高度竞赛才发生的。他们想找到更多的楼层，他们想获得更多的高度。因此，我们喜爱的克莱斯勒大厦那优雅修长的穹顶，就是这场愚蠢的高楼竞赛的结果。但最终让克莱斯勒大厦
that ultimately led the Chrysler building to surpass the Manhattan Company building for good was the gleaming spire called the vertex. And that was a 185 foot triangular spire that was built inside the stairwell, basically, the fire stairwell, inside the building at the top of the building so that Manhattan Company Building had no idea what was going on. They brought up each piece separately up the side of the building by Derrick's, constructed it inside the fire tower. And one day after the Manhattan Company Building was finished, topped out. No chance to add any more floors. Suddenly, this concealed vertex is brought up from inside the building. And as Van Allen said, sort of like a butterfly emerging from its cocoon,
彻底超越曼哈顿公司大厦的狡猾神来之笔，是一座被称为“顶点”的闪闪发光的尖顶。那是一个185英尺高的三角形尖顶，它是在建筑内部的楼梯间里——基本上是消防楼梯间里，在建筑顶端建造的，好让曼哈顿公司大厦完全不知道发生了什么。他们用井架将每一块部件分别运送到建筑侧面，并在消防塔内部进行组装。就在曼哈顿公司大厦完工封顶的一天之后，没有任何机会再加盖任何楼层时，这个隐藏的顶点突然从大厦内部被升起。正如范·艾伦所说，就像破茧而出的蝴蝶一样，
they put this thing on top of the building. It was 185 foot tall and it made the Chrysler building 1046 feet high in the tall structure in the world. Now surpassing the Eiffel Tower. And if you're thinking this stunt of secretly riveting a giant metal-spire 900 feet in the air sounds ridiculously dangerous, you are right. It's extremely dangerous. I can imagine today not getting approval. Everyone basically thinking from Chrysler to Van Allen is this thing going to fall. And if it does, you're going to impale half a street or more. And you can imagine
他们把这东西安在了建筑顶部。它高达185英尺，使克莱斯勒大厦的总高度达到1046英尺，成为了世界上最高的建筑，从而超越了埃菲尔铁塔。如果你认为这种在900英尺的高空中秘密铆接一个巨大金属尖顶特技听起来荒谬地危险，你是对的。这极其危险。我可以想象，在今天根本无法获得批准。基本上从克莱斯勒到范·艾伦每个人都在想，这东西会不会倒塌？如果倒塌了，你将会把半条街甚至更多的人串在上面。你可以想象
the damage that would have done. Now, you probably know and can clearly picture the now classic art deco style of the Chrysler building. The steel clad arches, the sunburst triangular windows, not to mention the hood ornament style, eagles, and the hub cap freezes. It was made for a car guy after all. But it's doubtful that you even heard of the Manhattan Company building. First, because now it's called Forty Wall Street or the Trump building. But also because it just never took hold in the public consciousness, even though I actually really dig its green roof. Curiously, the Manhattan Company building Forty Wall Street got all the accolades.
那会造成多大的破坏。现在，你可能知道并能清晰地勾勒出克莱斯勒大厦现在经典的装饰艺术风格。钢包覆的拱门、日冕状的三角形窗户，更不用说车头饰风格的雄鹰和轮毂盖饰带了。毕竟，它是为汽车迷打造的。但你大概连曼哈顿公司大厦都没听说过。首先，因为它现在被称为华尔街40号或特朗普大厦。但也因为它从未真正扎根于公众的意识中，尽管我其实真的很喜欢它绿色的屋顶。奇怪的是，曼哈顿公司大厦——华尔街40号获得了所有的赞誉。
It won awards, the design was mostly by this Japanese architect Yasui Matsui, so it did wonderful in the trades. And it was just basically a fairly bland looking building at the time. And then you have the Chrysler Building with this new dome, this new vertex, something that really New York or the world had never seen. It was pretty remarkable stuff and it was almost universally pan. It was considered a stunt design. What? Some people called it a monstrosity. No. It was largely reviled by architectural critics. What do they know? And it was only over time that the Chrysler building that the Christ of Building
它赢得了奖项，其设计主要出自这位日本建筑师Yasui Matsui之手，因此它在行业内表现极佳。它当时基本上只是一座看起来相当平庸的建筑。然后你再看看克莱斯勒大厦，有着这个新穹顶、这个新顶点，这是纽约乃至全世界从未见过的东西。这是相当了不起的事情，而且几乎遭到了普遍的抨击。它被认为是一个特技设计。什么？有些人称之为怪物。不。它在很大程度上遭到建筑评论家的抨击。他们懂什么？直到后来，克莱斯勒大厦才
became the sort of treasure landmark that it is. And if the story stopped there, you might think Van Allen, the artistic maverick, won the day. The Christ of Building was the tallest structure in the world. And even though the design was pan-originally, we all know that it eventually got its due. But the story does not end there.
成为如今这样备受珍视的地标。如果故事到此为止，你可能会认为充满艺术叛逆精神的范·艾伦取得了胜利。克莱斯勒大厦是世界上最高的建筑。尽管它的设计最初遭到了抨击，但我们都知道它最终得到了应有的认可。但故事并没有就此结束。
After all this hubbub, a partner against partner fighting for who would be the tallest, a mere 11 months later, the great Empire State Building was completed, and it became the tallest building in the world for nearly 40 years. Frankly, I don't care about that so much. What happened next was the real tragedy. The lack of business acumen that probably contributed to Van Allen and Severance parting ways really came back to bite William Van Allen. He never actually had a contract with Walter Chrysler to design the Chrysler building.
在经历了所有这些喧嚣之后，合伙人反目成仇，争夺谁将成为最高建筑，仅仅11个月后，伟大的帝国大厦便竣工了，它成为了近40年来世界上最高的建筑。坦率地说，我对此并不太在意。接下来发生的事情才是真正的悲剧。缺乏商业头脑可能促成了范·艾伦和塞弗伦斯的各奔东西，这确实给威廉·范·艾伦带来了沉重的反噬。他其实从来没有与沃尔特·克莱斯勒签过设计克莱斯勒大厦的合同。
Chrysler, at the end of the day, said, well, I'm not going to pay you your fee because we didn't have a sign contract. It was widely considered normal at the time for the architect to be paid roughly 6% of the cost of the building. That sum of money is what Van Al expected. It's what Chrysler wasn't willing to pay. Van Alen ended up suing Chrysler. It hit the newspapers and at the end of the day, Cass Gilbert, who did the wall work, came and said,
克莱斯勒到头来却说，好吧，我不会付给你设计费，因为我们没有签合同。当时，建筑师获得大约占建筑成本6%的报酬被广泛认为是很正常的。这笔钱正是范·艾伦所期望的，也是克莱斯勒不愿支付的。范·艾伦最终起诉了克莱斯勒。这上了报纸，最后，设计伍尔沃夫大厦的卡斯·吉尔伯特出面说，
you know, yes, that percentage is the typical rate. That's what Van Allen should be paid. Van Allen was paid that. But Van Allen was never given a major commission again. I think both because the Great Depression had hit and also because he had now sued his patron. And that was something that I think others shot away from. Van Allen spent most of the rest of his life teaching sculpture at the
你知道的，是的，那个百分比是典型费率，那是范·艾伦应该得到的报酬。范·艾伦拿到了那笔钱。但范·艾伦再也没有接到过重大项目。我认为，一方面是因为大萧条已经来临，另一方面也是因为他现在起诉了他的金主。我认为其他人对此都敬而远之。范·艾伦余生的绝大部分时间都在
Bozart's Institute of Design, but severance on the other hand continued to succeed. The Mahang Company building did terribly like every other office building in New York at the time. But Severance went into the depression and got a bunch of government work, actually built a bunch of hangars for balloons and such. And so he did quite well and lived nicely and died in luxury. So that's at least one happy ending for you. But we do have the happy ending in the fact that the Chrysler building is this sort of hollowed structure now.
博扎艺术设计学院教授雕塑，而塞弗伦斯则继续获得成功。曼哈顿公司大厦的表现惨不忍睹，就像当时纽约的其他所有写字楼一样。但塞弗伦斯挺过了大萧条，并接到了许多政府订单，实际上建造了一堆用于气球等的机库。所以他过得相当不错，生活优渥，并在奢华中离世。所以至少对你来说，这是一个大团圆结局。但我们在克莱斯勒大厦这座如今备受推崇的建筑上，确实迎来了大团圆结局。
And Van Allen really did get the commission of a lifetime. There was no expense spared by Chrysler. If you ever go into the Chrysler building, from the lobby all the way to the top, I mean, it's just expense and expense. I mean, just beautiful Art Deco interior work, wood paneling, Art Deco murals. It's just an incredible building top to bottom inside and out. And very rarely do you have a commission where money is no object. And so Vanone was given one shot and
范·艾伦确实接到了他一生中最好的项目。克莱斯勒不惜血本。如果你去过克莱斯勒大厦，从大堂一直到顶楼，我的意思是，到处都是金钱的堆砌。我的意思是，只有精美的装饰艺术风格内部装饰、木饰面、装饰艺术风格壁画。从上到下、从里到外，这是一座令人难以置信的建筑。非常罕见能碰到一个金钱不是问题的项目。所以范·艾伦得到了唯一的机会，
I think he came through. If Craig Severance was standing in front of me, I think I'd say, I wish you worked it out with Van Allen. You did well, you deserved it. But I think you would have been greater together. And if I could talk to Van Allen, I'd say, I'm sorry you didn't get to build more great structures, but know that you created the building that can stop the most architecturally blind and generally this interested person dead in their tracks, and they will marvel at your accomplishment. Know that.
我认为他成功了。如果克雷格·塞弗伦斯站在我面前，我想我会说，我真希望你能和范·艾伦把事情商量好。你干得不错，你实至名归。但我认为你们在一起会更伟大。如果我能和范·艾伦对话，我会说，很遗憾你没能建造更多伟大的建筑，但要知道，你创造了一座能够让那些对建筑最盲目、最不感兴趣的人也为之驻足的建筑，他们会惊叹于你的成就。记住这一点。
And to Walter Chrysler, I'd say, you pay your bills you deadbeat I could I mean we could have had another Chrysler building or something is good if you had ruined Van Allen's life I mean probably not because the Great Depression and all but we'll never know will we you bomb I'm gonna need a minute. 99% in visible is Sam Greenspan, Avery, Truppleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco, and produced out of the offices of Arxine, a brilliant architecture firm and beautiful downtown Oakland, California. When we get a little out of hand, they sometimes ask us to use our inside voices. But to that, I say, you should try working next to Snap Judgment. have judgment. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook.
至于沃尔特·克莱斯勒，我要说，你这个老赖快付账吧！我的意思是——我们本来可以再有一座克莱斯勒大厦或类似的好东西，如果你没有毁了范·艾伦的生活的话。我的意思是可能也不会，因为还有大萧条之类的事情，但我们永远不会知道了，对吧？你这个混蛋。我需要缓一分钟。《99%隐形》的制作人员有萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁普曼，还有我——罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在奥克兰市中心一座精美的建筑事务所Arxine的办公室里制作，那里充满艺术气息。当我们有点失控时，他们有时会要求我们使用室内音量。但对此我想说，你应该尝试在《快照判决》隔壁办公。你可以去Facebook上寻找并关注这个节目。
I tweet at Roman Mars, Sam tweets at Sam listens, Avery tweets at Troubleman. But right now, it is the first episode of season 4 where we are going weekly from here on out. So now is a great time to tell everyone you know and love to start listening to 99% invisible and everything you need to become to 99% invisible and everything you need to become a 99% invisible fan is available at 99pod.org. Radio to Pia. From PRX.
我在推特上是@RomanMars，萨姆是@Samlistens，艾弗里是@Troubleman。但现在，这是第四季的第一集，从现在开始我们将改为每周更新。所以现在是告诉所有你认识和喜爱的人开始收听《99%隐形》的最佳时机，成为一名《99%隐形》粉丝所需的一切都可以在99pod.org上找到。来自PRX的Radiootopia。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这一集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。